one of the reasons we were fascinated by
primes is there they are quite weird in
the way they behave on one hand they
kind of feel random they're turning up
all over the place sometimes do you have
these long gaps between primes and then
suddenly you like buses you get a couple
of primes turn up at once on the other
hand there are things that we can
predict about primes and when they're
going to turn up which is slightly
unexpected that you can do that they're
not a completely random
one of the first things I want to show
you then it's quite nice it's a nice
easy thing so everyone can do this at
home we're going to write the numbers in
a square spiral you start with one in
the middle then you write two but you go
around it four five six seven eight do
you see the pattern then it says square
spiral 12 13 14 15 it's called an olim
spiral stannis wha-hoo lamb he was a
Polish mathematician and he left Poland
just before World War two and he went to
America and he worked on the Manhattan
Project after World War two he went into
academia the story of this spiral is it
was he was sat in a very boring lecture
in academia it was in 1963 and so he's
obviously a fan of I heart of someone he
sat there doodling during this boring
lecture and he's writing out the numbers
30 31 32 the next thing he did was start
to circle the prime numbers let's do
that two is a prime and then 3 and then
5 and 7 and 11 13 not 40 41 43 is prime
and so on and he noticed I maybe you can
see these stripes the prime numbers seem
to be lining up on diagonal lines and if
you do this larger if you do more and
more numbers and you write them out in a
spiral that tends to be the case I've
got one here this is a big
ulam spiral I think this is something
huge I think this like 200 by 200 and so
there's 40,000 numbers or something here
can you see though can you see the
stripes there's definitely some stripes
here's these diagonal lines so the prime
numbers seem to be lying on diagonal
lines or to put it another way some
diagonal lines have lots of primes and
some diagonal lines don't have lots of
primes so so you can see the stripes
start to form I like continuous stripes
they look a bit broken up to me yeah
they're not continuous stripes but I
they have more than average number of
primes so these stripes might be a good
place to look for more Prime's bigger
Prime's new Prime's one thing people
might say is oh we're just seeing
patterns in in randomness that those
aren't really stripes at all it's just
the human brain thing if you compare it
with randomness this AR same size these
are random numbers and you can see it's
pretty much white noise there's no I
can't really see any pattern in this you
can see that that is random and you can
see that that is something more than
just being random these ginormous
Prime's that get found are they found on
diagonals like its largest prime known
was that on a diagonal the largest prime
known was a Mersenne prime which is of
the type 2 to the power n minus 1 it's
one less than a power of two which is a
way to look for large primes it's
computationally it's kind of easier to
do it's not the most perhaps it's not
the most fruitful way because they're
quite rare Mersenne primes this might be
another way to do it because this stripe
here this diagonal has an equation this
equation is for this one here this half
line which means it starts at 3 and goes
off to infinity the equation for that is
4x squared minus 2x
plus one and let me just try it let's do
the first one here so if X is equal to
one
yeah that's three if we tried the next
one here x equals to 13 and this one
here that's 31 and well this testers
let's do one more just to show you what
comes next 56 plus 57 is that prime
number Brady
57 is not up for another prime number so
the next one isn't a prime number but 57
would be the next number on that line so
that's one of the rates in our dotted
line yeah
so all these lines they in fact
horizontal lines vertical lines and
diagonal lines door like this those
quadratic equations that like that so
what we're saying is some quadratic
equations have more Prime's on them than
others and that's that's the conjecture
actually that hasn't been proved but
that is the conjecture it seems to be
the case so there are though there are
lines here that have like seven times as
many Prime's as other lines and there
are the best we found is a diagonal line
that has 12 times as many Prime's
as as the average cool is that line got
a nine and I can write it down for I
think I had it somewhere yeah a lot know
about line is the golden line there's
this golden line that Brady is now
decided to call it it actually starts
off it's a quadratic equation it starts
off quite simply again but the number
you add on is not plus one it's plus
something huge this square spiral is
called Elim spiral but there's a nice
this one I like even more it's called a
sac spiral and it works like this you
write the square numbers in a line the
square numbers are one for you know it's
2 squared 3 squared is 9 16 25 and so on
so you write the square numbers in the
light then I connect them with a what is
called an Archimedean spiral
like that
and then I would put the other numbers
on that spiral so go one and
evenly-spaced it so it goes one two
three four five six seven eight nine and
if you mark off the primes for that I've
got this already sorted out for you
this is the picture you get and you can
see the relations you can see the
pattern even more strikingly I think
look at these curves these are the
primes and obviously you will never get
a prime along there and that's where
those are your squares that big gap
there's the squares yeah so it looks
like we have formulas equations that
have some formulas anyway to have more
Prime's than others so if we can
understand these formulas that contain
these these rich number of primes then
it would help us solve important
conjectures in mathematics such as the
gold back conjecture and the twin prime
conjecture
so when prime numbers are not as random
as you might think of there are
equations to help us find prime numbers
and then now I want to show you some
equations that help you find prime
numbers so we'll have more about ways to
search for prime numbers coming really
soon from this interview with James
Graham unless you're watching this in
the future in which case the stuff might
already be on YouTube but you get the
idea but I have bit of a confession to
make
I've actually recorded some stuff about
these spirals and prime numbers before
not with James grime but with James
Cluett and I kind of half forgot about
it and never got around to editing it
this was like a year and a half ago I
went back and had a look and it was
actually really interesting so I've
turned that into a video as well now you
can wait for that to turn up in your
subscriptions in the next few days or if
you can't wait you can go and have a
look at it now I've made the links
available the videos already up so go
ahead and have a look thanks for
watching plenty more videos soon both of
stuff I've recorded
some of quite a while ago it turns out
and stuff we've still got to record
really exciting stuff coming soon on
numberphile so make sure you've
subscribed